the Joe Rogan experience car you drive
so I now have a test for ya
so I ponied up their expensive by the
way sorry yes I have the X so that's my
sort of utility vehicle the X is the the
SUV a very high acceleration as you know
and but yeah there's there's no
maintenance on it right there's no oil
change there's no you know the only
moving part is the what you turn in the
wheels with right there no Pistons
nothing so you know cars really should
have been this 100 years ago and then we
would have had a hundred years of clever
engineering to perfect that you ever see
the documentary who killed the electric
car no I haven't but I know about it and
I know some of the background story
behind it and the electric car was one
of the first concern because electricity
was all the rage a hundred years ago
let's electrify the cities this days
there's Edison there's Tess everybody
wants to do everything electric and the
car had just come out let's do it
electric so this was not a new concept
and it's unfortunate that more sort of
innovative thinkers hadn't been brought
to task on how to perfect the electric
car
speaking of Tesla electricity what did
you think about Tesla's initial idea
that Westinghouse shot down to sort of
broadcast electricity so that people
could just pull it out of the air yes so
the the people in the nikola tesla fan
club somehow feel that he got wronged in
his life okay and surely some of that is
true with regard to his business acumen
and patents and and who owns the patent
and who does does he have good business
sense is he as savvy or as as sneaky
whatever other words you might apply to
Edison alright so I get that but his
contributions to electromagnetism are
real and recognized in the world of
physics like I said there's a unit of
electromagnetism named after him so
don't come crying to me say he was not
recognized by my people
okay he's recognized he had some ideas
that were a little out there and out
there on a level where it almost
certainly would have not worked and
here's why okay
electromagnetic
energy is communicating between us I see
you that's because visible light is
reflecting off of your scalp okay to me
it's reflecting off of my nose back to
you you can ask how much energy is in
that well not much it's not much energy
in a visible light photons if you stayed
there long enough you might feel a
little warmth from it but no you're not
gonna drive a car with that energy
you're not gonna run a motor with it
okay
well of what good is it oh you know what
we found we can use electromagnetic
radio waves which are the lowest form of
electromagnetic energy lowest energy
level of all of your life we can
straight away it's not to transmit
energy that's not the point of it the
point is to transmit information and
information became what characterized
the modern era and that's why in the
1950s and 60s when everyone is imagining
flying cars and motorized sidewalks
everything is running on energy because
they're thinking energy is gonna be free
in the future but what they didn't
figure was that information would be
free or easy to transmit and to generate
and to store and to to delete and
whereas the the energy that would take
to move things and to drive things that
would be a problem no one saw that
coming nobody saw that coming
so as your photons get higher and higher
energy yes you can start doing things
with them you get x-rays and gamma-rays
but that's not what Tesla was referring
to he was talk about moving radio waves
through the space that would charge
things up you can't pack sufficient
energy in your radio wave to do anything
we need to do
mechanically currently currently well
back then would it be sufficient there
might have been something you could have
done with your radio waves cuz the needs
were no but no snow I take that back
that was the height of the industrial
revolution that was the age of the
Machine the age of the giant turbines
radio energy is not touching that well
but wasn't it possible that he was
considering it for things like radios or
light bulbs or
household items would it be possible to
use that power for that so now what so
what happens so the radio waves if you
had enough power in radio waves to
generate a light bulb to power a light
bulb well through the air are you
standing in the way of this this energy
has pathways we now send energy through
wires because you're not standing in the
way of the wire the wire is buried the
wire has insulation high suspension you
want to move it through the air and you
want to walk around like no that's not
how that works but what I've heard if
you're moving in our energy through the
air to power something that itself could
kill you the energy powering through
that moving through the air could kill
you unless you you bring a little bit
amount and then you store it and then
use it later you could do it that way
sure so we're sort of batteries yes you
need a storage system but you would
still probably have some sort of
residual effect of having this stuff
broadcast through the air and who knows
what it would do to human health if you
needed that much energy right now the
energy to transmit information is so low
that it no it has no effect on your
health that's why I can pull out my cell
phone I'm in a brick whether this is
fake brick that's fake brick I'm in a
Bill's real brick that no it's nice it
is go touch it I don't believe you good
how's it real bricks go touch the bricks
man Jesus Christ he thinks we got fake
bricks weird now let me be honest it's a
veneer a brick veneer okay the whole
thing real building so it's not
structural brick slice the end of bricks
and then they mortar okay so so we're
both right but it's not structural it's
real fabric so here I am a real fake so
we're inside I can pull out my cell
phone and have a phone call yes these
are microwaves of a frequency that can
penetrate walls send information to my
cell phone and I can communicate using
information and not have that energy
kill me but it's not enough to power the
actual it is not enough to power the
device correct so until
Tesla's everyone's thinking he's got the
solution to the future transmission of
energy no he doesn't well I don't think
anyone's saying that but he did and his
fans do but back then there were no
computers back then there were no
television but we did have machines it
was the era of the big machine right but
I don't think he was insinuating that
you could use I don't know what he
wanted to power with history I don't
know what he would have powered with if
not light bulbs and other things
[Applause]